So again, the correct response for
this query is to take the mean of the K,
where K is equal to 3,
nearest neighbors.
Take the mean of their Y-value,
and that gives us a value
somewhere about like there.
If we were to repeat
this process at many,
many points along the X-axis, we end
up with a model that looks like this.
What's nice about it is it fits the data
over here where it's curving this way.
It fits the data over here
where it's curving that way.
And in interpolates nicely and
smoothly between all the data points.
There are number of methods like
this that keep the data around and
when they make a query, they consult
the data to find the answer.
The most famous of these
methods is K nearest neighbor.
But there are others,
such as kernel regression.
The main way that KNN differs
from kernel regression is that in
kernel regression we weight
the contributions of each of the nearest
data points according to
how distant they are.
Where as with KNN,
each data point that we consider
gets essentially an equal weight.
We've covered now parametric models,
where our goal is to find
parameters like M and B.
And we toss the data away, and
then just use M and B later to make
our queries and here I've shown
you non-parametric or instance
based methods where we keep the data and
we consult it when we make a query.